let's go next to
um oh where are we going there's so many
interesting callers let's go to louie
from new brunswick louie you're on the
air
hey good afternoon david can you hear me
i can hear you fine
so i really enjoy your show for some
caller long time listener uh my wife and
i find ourselves in a strange situation
okay we we we're uh
part of a
a church that's very very right-leaning
uh but politically we're the opposite
except for some key issues
we feel like we have to almost keep it
under wraps um our political
uh bent
but um
we really have a hard time discussing
uh just just just common issues with our
you know with our brothers and sisters
uh have you have you ever encountered
anything like this before and
what do you do yeah i mean i guess in
some sense i have in that
there i mean listen i'm not a religious
jew i'm culturally jewish
ethnically jewish culinarily jewish i'm
not religious but
there are people in my circles who are
more religiously
devout jews
and they have much more culturally
conservative views but it's not really
become a problem it's just like i know
those are their views and they know my
views let me ask what what denomination
or what is this is this a christian
church
it is it's a christian church where
basically non-denominational
uh and the funny thing is that our
congregation is becoming extremely
multicultural i'll give you a quick
example
we had a
a christmas
uh well it's an advent children's uh
concert i would like to say and
i want to say 90 of the children were
uh non-white
okay and it was a great sight like i i
you know our our leadership is saying
things like
look if our if our community is very
multicultural then the church should
represent that right so i love that i
love that however i've noticed that uh
a lot of the the men in the leadership
uh or i would say not the leadership a
lot of the men who are very engaged uh
are are a lot more i would say caucasian
and then skew heavily towards
i hate to say this but trumpism well i
mean let me just ask you what what's
like a big issue on which you disagree
with the general position of the church
um well well that's just it like it's
not a position of the church to to to
follow politics but um
but but when a lot of people you know
are like just spouting
uh things that they heard on fox news
and worse like uh
newsmechs yeah it's really it's really
horrible like for example we were in a
prayer meeting and someone was like like
praying against nancy pelosi it was like
it was literally like a fox news talking
point now in a situation i mean listen i
don't know anything about churches but
in a situation like that couldn't you
stand up and say listen guys
um it's not appropriate for us to be
involving politics in this way i'm not
making a statement for or against anyone
i'm just saying this is a place for
faith and community not for politics
like could could you say that or would
that not be well received
well uh we have said that actually in
our men's meeting we've made a point
that like we shall not ever talk
politics because it it's so divisive
right and
uh and when i've confronted people
one-on-one about say like hypocrisy of
trump or like daddy lies or he's like a
you know he's abused women or done
horrible things i've noticed that it it
hurts people's feelings and like they
record they recoil like they were uh you
know personally injured
so so my wife and i have learned like
just not even to bring it up and we just
cringe and kind of like just hold their
tongue when
when things come up could you find a
more liberal church i mean is that an
option i mean i i understand it's a big
deal to change churches i'm sure but but
is it to the point where you would say i
want to find a different church well
it's funny that you bring that up
because a lot of people who have spoken
about this outside the church say stuff
like that like why don't you leave dude
like why are you still there
and and the you know what it is is like
there's so much love there's so much
relationships we've been there for over
10 years we feel like we feel like
um
it would be like abandoning that it's
just not an option it's worth it i think
just to like stay in the labor of love
and like just see how things turn out
well in that case it sounds like you
have your answer as to what to do right
yeah yeah you're right yeah we're
staying yeah yeah yeah you sound pretty
pretty confident about that all right
well let me know how it goes and by the
way i mean listen
you're not saying that from the pulpit
they're doing politics right because
that's actually against the church
charter for non-profits
right no they're not there there's even
when even when trump was like flying
high and things were like uh you know in
in their perspective because now it's
the opposite like uh you know it's it's
almost like a shame now i think for even
for trump is to talk about trump but
um or to defend him i should say but
even when when he was flying high i
would say like
early in his uh
in his administration yeah
there were times where i have a feeling
that the pastor crossed the line and
people had to talk to him and say you
need to you need to dial that back like
oh interesting you can't yeah so
it's a struggle especially with the
older
the older generation i would say like
over 50 over 60. got it got it all right
we'll keep us posted on how it goes yeah
thanks louie louie from new brunswick
dealing uh that's quite a matzo ball
hanging out there that he's dealing with
proverbially of course i know it's a
christian uh a christian church
i love growing my own food at home many
of you have seen my gardening stuff on
my instagram i get great tips from the
audience and one of our sponsors is
lettuce grow which is by far the easiest
way to grow your own food at home
the lettuce grow farm stand is a
hydroponic unit that waters and
fertilizes itself you can grow more than
200 varieties of fruits and veggies at
home indoors or outdoors
i love my lettuce grow farm stand i've
grown edible flowers tomatoes
strawberries eggplant it only requires
five minutes of maintenance a week i can
grow 36 plants at a time it uses 95
percent less water than traditional
gardening no packaging
no waste i didn't even know it was
possible to grow food like this in a
portable unit but i love it and lettuce
grow is giving you fifty dollars off the
farm stand when you go to
lettucegrow.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below